yeah I mean everything's a fractal of  everything else so a lot of times if  people are on it to a certain type of  journey or have enhanced perceptions we  see fractals we see mirrors we've heard  the phrase consciousness as a Hall of  Mirrors so the physical world mirrors  the astral and vice-versa in certain  ways same with the causal karmic same  with the seventh plane which is where  our divinities hang out mostly and it's  it's nice because then we can use one  reality our main third dimensional  physical reality as a mirror and a bit  of a map for understanding everything  else so how do we use the three  dimensional reality as a mirror for the  fourth dimension how does that work how  does that mirror